hi there steve kaufman here again
and today i'm going to talk about you
know learning the basics
in a language uh remember if you enjoy
these videos
please subscribe click on the bell to
get notifications
and by all means join me at link which
is where i learn languages
so the reason i want to talk about the
basics is because
in my previous video i talked about
learning a language from scratch
and as i did so it struck me that you
know in a language
you know it's a bit like getting into a
swimming pool i mean the water is
equally wet everywhere so you just have
to get in
and start swimming and
very often people talk about sort of
mastering the basics and mastering the
core vocabulary and
mastering certain core concepts and and
i've never
found that to be a very useful uh
concept and and i'll explain why before
that i should
mention a few things people are
commenting that i look tired that i have
red eyes and stuff
okay how tired i look in a video may
depend on
what time of the day i do the video
morning or evening
second of all i'm in palm spring india
california to be exact right now
and if i go swimming in the pool my eyes
get a bit red
and furthermore i look into a sort of a
halo light
that also seems to give me a bit of a
red-eye look so
all of those things might explain my
appearance i'm going to be here till may
28th
um yeah we decided my wife and i to
leave vancouver for a few weeks we snuck
out the government
canadian government discourages people
from traveling but
uh actually the incidence of covet is
much less now in the states certainly in
california
than it is in british columbia we were
also able to get our second pfizer shot
down here
so we're hopeful that by the time we go
back home
they won't make it too difficult for us
uh we don't mind
uh quarantining hopefully we don't have
to stay in a hotel if we can cross
the border at some point other than at
the airport
we will see what happens anyway getting
back to
the basics so i don't really and i've
said this before oh and another thing
too i'm trying to figure out the best
place to look
into my camera here and there's various
squares and circles
so i hope i'm doing it you know in a way
that is the least
distracting to people now getting back
to the subject
so when i did my learning indonesian
from scratch i didn't start from lesson
one
i started from lesson two and i said you
could just as easily start from lesson
five or less than 10
and go back to one or three or eight and
it really doesn't matter
and the reason is the following that
obviously some stories some content
is easier and some stories are easier
than others
and they are easier because they have a
lot of high
frequency vocabulary or vocabulary that
you
know that's familiar to you that's how
we design the mini stories
vocabulary repeats five times in a story
uh and we've tried to design the many
stories
so that you know in these 60 minutes
stories we have a lot of high
frequency verbs useful verbs give
go come take need want etc
so if you get a lot of repetition that's
going to make them easier
however the trouble with frequency as
i've said before is that it declines
very very quickly
so the high frequency vocabulary is
going to show up you needn't worry about
learning it
it will show up if you expose yourself
to enough
content that's not a concern the most
common structures in the language
will show up patterns like subject verb
object all of these things will appear
fairly soon
even if they are explained to you it
doesn't mean that you will
get it so to me
you know trying to nail down the basics
is somewhat
futile and probably unnecessary
certain things are basic for example so
and the other thing too is that in a
language
you know it's not like in math if you
don't have
sort of basic skills basic mathematical
skills
you can't do the next level of skill
i talked about swimming if you don't
have a basic swimming stroke
you know the ability to float then you
can't build on that to develop
more advanced swimming strokes or
swimming skills
but language is not like that language
is just words
it's not obvious that the present tense
is easier than the past tense it depends
on the language it depends how complex
these conjugations are
it's just words and the more you hear
the words the more the brain gets used
to the words the more
the brain gets used to different
structures the sooner it's going to
be able to operate in the language and
all of this is achieved as you know i
repeat this all the time
through massive input listening and
reading
and i tried to show you in the last
video how
even in the language that i don't know
just by exposing myself to enough of the
content
the language start the language will
start to seep into me and of course
the things that repeat the most often
which are going to be the high frequency
of verbs
or high frequency words they will be the
things that i start
to learn someone said what about
languages that use a completely
different script like indonesian uses
the latin alphabet
it makes it more difficult and you still
have to work on learning that script
but even there if you learn the script
so theoretically
you have been exposed to what this
symbol represents
if it's a an alphabet like the persian
or the arabic alphabet
that doesn't mean that you're
comfortable reading in that alphabet
or with the you know cyrillic alphabet
or the greek alphabet
or hangul in korean it doesn't mean
you're comfortable you still have to put
so much effort into reading so much
that the brain starts to get used to
something that
in a way is basic like the script if you
can't read the script you're not gonna
be able to read
so gaining some familiarity with the
script
if it's different from say the latin
alphabet in a way is basic
there's a situation where you do have
something that's basic where you have a
skill that's required in order to go
forward
whereas vocabulary it's more a matter of
of what you you know come across
in your listening and reading and
inevitably the
most frequent 70 of words are going to
show up and you're going to get to know
them fairly
soon so i think this this uh
this obsession with the basics and
building on the basics
basics in language learning is misplaced
it's not like
you have to learn the basics of math
before you can get into engineering
before you can build a bridge
and there's a lot of sort of knowledge
that builds on prior
knowledge in language if you were
totally dedicated to say
learning the terms for cooking in
persian because you were
only interested in persian food then you
would learn
all of the terms
that are connected to the cuisine and
those would be vocabulary items that
maybe for someone else would be
very difficult because they wouldn't see
them that often but if you were
constantly dealing with
recipes and how to make different dishes
in persian food or french food or
chinese food then those would be your
high frequency
words that you would learn so that there
are really no
basics you gradually become familiar now
at some point
you develop a curiosity why does the
language work this way versus
that way and at that point you can look
up explanations
but if you try to master the
explanations up front because
these are the basic structures of the
language or this is the basic
vocabulary and so i'm going to you know
get the most
you know the highest frequency 500 words
and learn them
in fact your brain won't get used to
them just by the fact that you
study these lists you still have to go
through the process
of listening and reading and allowing
your brain to get used to the language
so i i think i've said this before but
it's a theme that
that has kind of come back to me now
because of the fact that i did that
video about learning from scratch and i
reminded myself
of the fact that in fact i was having a
conversation with someone i think in
turkish or in persian
and my tutor said you know you only ever
talk about
you know economics and social problems
and politics uh what about
things from daily life in fact my
vocabulary
uh surrounding you know things in daily
life and food and clothing and stuff
was nowhere near as well developed as
this other
vocabulary because that's what i was
interested in that's what i was learning
that's what i was coming across so our
political terms
basic and carrot banana
strawberry less basic i don't know
it all depends on what you're interested
in you just have to expose yourself to
the language
and gradually allow the brain to get
used to it and don't try to nail down
the basics
i think it's a bit of a futile exercise
thank you for listening bye for now